we
okay we're doing well almost there
they can give the same speech
okay let's let's all sit please I don't
see anybody else coming in the back okay
excellent see journalists are always on
time well good afternoon everybody i'm
nick lemon the dean of the Graduate
School of Journalism and I want to
extend a warm and wet welcome to the
members of the class of 2011 and their
families every year at our graduation
ceremony they let me make a few remarks
before we get to the heart of the event
as long as I promise to keep them brief
so that's where we are now I'm somewhat
notorious around here for not having
gone to journalism school when this fact
is flung in my face I usually sheepishly
argue that I was lucky enough to have
had extraordinary mentors in my first
few newsrooms who collectively comprise
an informal school of journalism that's
true as far as it goes but it isn't the
real story during the past two academic
years I've taught three different
courses here history of journalism
evidence and inference and the art of
the interview in all three cases I will
now confess I was not passing on the
wisdom and knowledge that I've
accumulated over the course of decades
of working as a journalist I was instead
learning the material myself for the
first time so that i could teach it to
my students to make the point more
broadly i sometimes think that my
becoming dean here was a secret plot on
my part to get myself the journalism
education that I never had
and what I've taught myself in my eight
years here in order to teach it to my
students has made me a better working
journalists during the limited time that
I have to be one as a journalist in even
a great news organization you're living
life in two dimensions you have access
only to what are the best practices in
your own institution and its peers and
it is almost irresistible attempting to
assume that those practices are
journalism but as a student here you are
not trapped inside one moment in time
one country or one corner of the news
business you can see what we do in three
dimensions instead of to an immediate
effect of that is to make you see that
journalism is incredibly various it
includes everything from statistical
surveys to horoscopes and comic strips
from political activism to high
objectivity from investigation to in
election from nonfiction books to tweets
and right now journalism is getting more
various not less seeing how many
different forms journalism takes poses a
definitional challenge to us as
journalists and educators in my youth it
was at least possible to argue that
journalism is whatever appears in a
metropolitan daily newspaper or whatever
appears in another medium that is
linearly descended from what appears in
a newspaper or to argue that a pyramid
style news story is the basic unit of
journalism it's not possible to be that
specific anymore we now have to define
journalism as a function not as a
particular mode of presentation
journalists are people who actively seek
out the truth of a situation with all
due humility about the difficulty of
that project but with real confidence
and aggressiveness we usually have to do
this quickly and therefore we have to
make difficult judgments on the basis of
in
complete or conflicting information we
present the material we found in a clear
accurate engaging form that a general
audience will find compelling and
persuasive but let me remind you I'm
resorting to this functional definition
in response to the great proliferation
of forms of journalism not because as
people often say these days the familiar
forms of journalism are converging into
one now I know that on a news website
one can post text of any length still
photography sound and video but there
are not yet very many news organizations
that sustain themselves by doing all
those things at once equally well we
still have a newspaper business and a
magazine business and a radio business
and a television business all looking
less doomed than they might have a
couple of years ago even within the
world of online journalism we're seeing
more differentiation not more
convergence websites that are excellent
advise excellent at text and vice versa
tablet journalism just emerging seems to
be different from website journalism
higher production values less
interactive mobile device journalism is
developing its own distinctive norms to
another way of thinking about this idea
of convergence in the future of
journalism is in terms of the daily
routine of a typical young journalist
somebody like you one version has it
that instead of living at the leisurely
quazy academic pace of say Hilde Johnson
in the front page producing a daily
story in text only for a morning edition
you will all be frenetically filing
shooting posting tweeting and updating
continuously through every 24 hour news
cycle each individual journalists will
produce more material for more platforms
at a relatively low level of
sophistication because there's no time
for a high level of sophistication given
the experience that many of you have had
every day at this school and it worked
before you arrived here and that you
will have immediately upon leaving I
can't very well look you in the eye and
tell you that this kind of journalistic
life doesn't exist but i would like to
lay out an alternative vision of the
future of journalism in the digital age
i will call it leveraged journalism let
me return for a moment to my own late in
life journalism education columbia is a
research university that means our
faculty does research as well as
teaching and these two fundamental
activities reinforce each other for most
of our faculty research means producing
works of journalism at a high level for
me one of the great pleasures of being
Dean here is being able to spend my days
with colleagues who are so engaged but
lately we have been taking on a second
research mission research about
journalism our profession is changing so
rapidly that we just don't have a full
reliable picture of what's going on and
this school has the good fortune to be
one of the few journalistic institutions
in the world with the capability to help
create that missing picture as we'd say
in our business this is a monster story
and it's on us to cover it lots of
people in the journalism building
faculty members students staff members
at Columbia Journalism Review take their
own cuts at this topic the aggregate of
their individual work represents a major
contribution by the school and the
school itself has begun commissioning
research we've published two major and
widely discussed reports in the last
year and a half the first published in
october two thousand nine was the
reconstruction of American journalism by
Leonard Downie michael hudson and
christopher anderson it focused on the
public and nonprofit sectors and on
media policy among its many good effects
was helping lead to a major report on
the same subject by the Federal
Communications Commission which will be
made public soon
our second report published just last
week was the story so far by Bill grew
skin' our academic dean Avis Eve and
Lucas graves it focuses on the market
economics of digital journalism and it
is getting attention every bit as wide
and favorable as our previous report I
hope we will publish a third report of
similar ambition and impact but on a
different topic about a year and a half
from now my hidden agenda in
commissioning these reports is to use
them to educate myself as dean about
where our profession is headed and so to
find out how the journalism school can
be most useful useful both as a teaching
institution and as a public voice in
response to the reconstruction of
American journalism report I devoted
this talk last year to urging our
graduates to learn about and engage in
the ongoing debate on media policy
something that journalists of my
generation were taught not to do because
sometime it would Sully our purity
reading the story so far report is what
led me to begin thinking about what I
just called leverage journalism the
report makes it clear that digital
journalism is profoundly different from
what digital folks like to call legacy
journalism among the differences is that
digital news organizations as of now
have much smaller staffs than legacy
organizations but much bigger audiences
and much more powerful tools with which
to produce journalism so the most useful
way to think about the life of a digital
journalist I hope is not as somebody who
carries a back-breaking load of
individual production responsibilities
instead it's as somebody who figures out
creative ways to use her own
extraordinary capabilities including
digital skills analytic ability
storytelling flair and subject matter
expertise to blend a small but crucial
measure of the work of her own two hands
with a much larger measure of the work
of
thurs this work can include aggregation
and curation of news produced by other
organizations imaginatively locating and
presenting material that is already in
the public record and using members of
the audience as contributors of content
I don't know exactly how this is going
to work but it's something that we as a
school and you as journalists must
explore aggressively we will be planning
new curriculum and continuing to
research what's going on in digital
journalism you should be thinking about
how to use the skills you have to the
highest possible advantage by making
them the defining aspect of work that
does not have to be produced entirely by
you finally bear in mind that you're not
really leaving the journalism school
this afternoon your status will change
in about an hour from students to alumni
but that is still an active status we
will be following your achievements with
love and pride and we will be relying on
you by your example and by you're
actively letting us know to keep us
informed about where this incredibly
fast changing profession is going we are
all on a great collective adventure and
we shouldn't let a little thing like
graduation diminish the sense that we're
all in it together thank you
in line with my last point you either
noticed or are unconsciously sitting on
j-school tote bag which represents a
symbolic embodiment of your transition
to being alums so from now on you must
carry everything in your j-school tote
bag as you move throughout the world and
cover big stories I now want to bring to
the stage the aforementioned dean of
academic affairs of the school bill
grusin who will introduce our student
speaker bill
this is the last time you'll ever hear
me say this that is a fine-looking class
we got out here and I promise I won't
say to next year's class the Society of
Professional Journalists is an
international organization of reporters
for broadcast print and digital media
and photo journalists who support each
other and provide examples of best
practices of journalism they remind us
to hold ourselves to the highest
standards of ethics integrity and
getting the story right as well as
advocating the protection of First
Amendment and its guarantees of freedom
of speech and press through its advocacy
efforts at the Columbia Graduate School
of Journalism we have a student chapter
of the Society of Professional
Journalists or as we call it in our
hashtags spj which also serves as the de
facto student government all the
officers are elected at the beginning of
the fall term this year Zara Raja was
elected the president
she was a dynamo of creativity
intellectual endeavor and goodwill both
for the students and for those of us up
on the seventh floor who like to know
what's really going on on the six floors
below us when Zara was asked why she
wanted to become president of the spj
she said after a month of being
surrounded by these amazing people i
knew i wanted to get a chance to work
with them i thought the best way to get
to know them was by serving as president
please join me in welcoming the 2011
class president Zara Raja
Thank you Thank You Dean briskin Thank
You Dean lemon faculty administrators
guests and the class of 2011 good
afternoon and welcome to our graduation
we made it I would however like to begin
with some fact checking if I may when
the MS students arrived at the j-school
in August we were put through a digital
media boot camp now we were told the
boot camp would end in three weeks but
ladies and gentlemen a correction is an
order it lasted almost forty two weeks
the entire program is a boot camp and
has only just come to a screeching halt
the class of 2011 that is just cross the
finishing line is an extraordinary one
made up of remarkable people in the past
ten odd months we have not only made
huge leaps forward in our knowledge base
and skill sets we have also endured
insufferable hardship caused of course
by courses like rw1 and eni if you do
not know what either of those acronyms
means thank your stars for you have been
spared but in all seriousness some of
our fellow students have faced some of
life's most difficult challenges along
with juggling their schoolwork they have
lost loved ones undergone surgery lost
their funding and yet they have stayed
the course for some of our international
students english is a second third or
fourth language yet they've managed to
write at a level unimaginable to them
even a couple of years ago and one of
our students actually went through her
entire pregnancy the school year and
with the birth of baby with the birth
and and with the birth of her baby our
number has actually grown by one and we
the class of 2011 have survived the
coldest winter in New York history I can
safely say that this group of people are
the most determined hard-working some of
the smartest yet the most friendly and
fun bunch of people I have ever met and
that is why it's an honor to be part of
this family now like all families we are
somewhat dysfunctional but in the end we
are indeed the few the poor and the
proud so I applaud you now there's one
thing that I really like to share with
you today and that's something that's
been said to me repeatedly over the past
school year and that is j school is all
about choices Jerry school is all about
choices number of people have told me
that and I like to dwell on this idea of
choice just briefly for example we all
picked different concentrations in our
various programs this year as some of us
learned the hard way choices are
important and while that might be true
for anyone graduating I would argue that
it is of particular importance to young
journalists and journalists and training
today because above and beyond our
abilities and capabilities to report and
produce what will really matter is what
we decide to do with them this is true
in terms of building careers in an
industry which is in great flux yes but
more importantly choice matters because
in journalism or journalism as added in
its heart of hearts is a creative
profession at its heart as you know very
well lies the art of storytelling and so
as artists we make crucial decisions not
every day not every hour but every
minute we make them in the stories we
choose to report the people we speak to
for those stories the perspectives we
include and the ways in which we package
and produce them
creative work it turns out is done
primarily through a process of
elimination our stories are written not
in the quotes and characters we include
but in those that we leave out it is
difficult to admit that absolute free
choice while an ideal is but a myth our
decisions are governed and limited by
the world around us but it is also our
knowledge or lack of it that limits us
for example we can only report that
coveted untold story if we know enough
about it in the first place and so one
of the best ways to give ourselves the
best chance possible at making the
freest the most independent and the most
ethical decision is by making it the
most and best informed and that ladies
and gentlemen I think is what we have
gained in our time at the school
knowledge with which to make these
decisions education yes is a
transformative experience and an
excellent education is above all an
empowering experience there are many
people to thank for this it's been an
incredibly exciting yet to be at the
j-school for all the new developments
going on in the building but also the
big news stories breaking around us and
that have visited us in the form of
journalists covering those stories
coming to the school first and foremost
on behalf of the student government and
our entire class I'd like to thank our
adviser abeka Castillo who could
unfortunate not be with us here today
but without whose support
but without his support guidance and
help we really could not have functioned
Rebecca I hope you're watching the live
stream thank you for everything and we
wish you a quick and full recovery the
spj board members have been
inspirational in their drive and energy
to do things for their fellow classmates
just in the past couple of months they
have put on events that classes have
been rescheduled to accommodate I cannot
claim credit for these and the other
initiatives some may request the spj
Board of 2011 to please stand and be
recognized for their phenomenal work
thank you I'd also like to thank our
teachers and mentors for their time and
dedication all the school staff for
their patience and hard work and
diligence and my fellow students for
keeping each other going I'd also like
to commend my class for being the first
standing class in the history of the
j-school to make a donation to the
school that will go towards scholarship
scholarships for other students so thank
you I project about finally I'd like to
thank my mother and my family and by
extension everyone's families and
friends who have supported us throughout
this year and indeed throughout our
lives Thank You mothers fathers sisters
brothers significant others uncles aunts
grandparents friends and pets we would
not have been here without you
so as we stand here at the threshold of
life beyond school I guess I can only
hope that the education and the
relationships that we have built here
will give us both the knowledge and the
courage to make not only the right
choices but also the daring ones
professor sig Gissler at the start of
the year urged us to descend into the
streets of New York with a sense of
joyful entitlement he said that was the
way to be a reporter and we thank him
for inspiring us with that but if I
could co-opt his phrase to say that I
wish for my class as we turn our
attention to the powers that be in the
fancy editorial offices and newsrooms
that we take with us a sense of joyful
empowerment let us make our choices and
find our voices and let our work and its
quality be the expression of that you
have something to say and the world
needs to hear it class of 2011 that I
hope will make you not journalistic
functionaries but the visionaries that
you are all more than capable of
becoming choose well be well
congratulations and thank you
every spring the faculty the dignitaries
assembled here of the journalism school
votes to confer the Columbia Journalism
Award the mean people in low library
over here will not let us give honorary
degrees only the university can give
honorary degrees but if we could this
would be our honorary degree and in fact
it's better than an honorary degree
because there's only one of them every
year supposed to the several honorary
degrees he's just so good for it this
morning this year the faculty voted to
confer the Columbia Journalism Award on
al Jazeera English this is only the
second time in the history of the award
that it's been given to an institution
the last time was 1993 and the recipient
was the NewsHour on PBS also at that
time a significant new positive
influence on journalism I should say
just on a personal note when I was
roughly your age and I was in the
aforementioned non journalism school
journalism school of life in my first
full-time job out of college I worked
for a very broke news organization
called the Washington Monthly a
political magazine before there was a
crisis in journalism we kind of invented
the crisis in journalism and that was
our daily life and it was never clear
whether you'd be paid when pay day came
and in the middle of all this bleakness
one day in the spring of I guess 1977 or
78 the word arrived that our editor and
publisher and founder had been given the
Columbia Journalism Award Charles Peters
and boy did that feel good so it's it's
not only meaningful on the giving end
but
hope it's meaningful and the receiving
end as well and it certainly was the
time that I was one step away from from
a recipient al Jazeera English started
in 2006 it's not yet five years old it's
become clearly one of the most
significant news organizations in the
world not just in in the English
language it has an enormous audience of
at least 80 million people is that a
good number 250 million sorry it's keeps
growing um it has it has bureaus in many
many countries around the world one of
the few places in the world where its
most difficult to watch is the United
States where as of today and I hope this
will change only three middle sized
cities carry al jazeera english on their
ordinary cable systems however when the
Arab Spring began many of us on the
stage and I'm sure many of us in the
room found that we could watch
al-jazeera English on the internet on
our computers and that it was the best
place to find out what was going on in
this chain of momentous events so we all
became addicts and really admiring
addicts we worthy by the this functional
standard I proposed earlier who tells
you on a truly enormous and complicated
and widespread and difficult to get to
story who gives you the closest to the
aggregate truth of the situation
aggressively and independently reported
it seemed to us that al Jazeera English
won that title so it educates us in
important ways there's another way it
educates us and that is on the one hand
and this is one of the complicated
things about journalism and and and Zara
just alluded to it herself on the one
hand the facts of a situation are the
facts of a situation and we have a
sacred duty to find them and report them
accurately and clearly on the other hand
there's a lot of art in the news and and
everybody around the world does not have
the same perspective everyone around the
world does not have the same news
judgment everyone around the world does
not think the exact same things are
important one of the most interesting
evenings at this school since I've been
Dean was the evening we had Richard
sambrook who was then one of the top
news officials at the BBC come and he
did a show on a screen it was at the
height of the Iraq war and he said ok
the Iraq war is going on it's a big
story everybody's covered i'm just going
to show you six different versions by
six great news organizations around the
world of what the story was on a
particular day no overlap six completely
different stories so another one of the
pleasures of watching al-jazeera English
on the internet and and I hope one day
soon on cable television is it's an
education not only on what's going on
particularly in the Middle East but also
in a different perspective on the news
from what we have in America there is
not total non overlap but there's not
total overlap either and and that's
quite interesting it's also the case
that there is not a unified Middle
Eastern perspective on the news as seen
by the fact that that one of Al
Jazeera's reporters Dorothy parvaz just
got sprung from captivity she was taken
captive in Syria where she went missing
and moved to Iran and then held for a
few days and I don't know how what you
do somehow just got out so
you you cannot get everybody everywhere
to agree that your version of the news
even if it's absolutely accurate is the
only possible version of the news and
that's what makes our jobs interesting
I'm about to bring to the stage a lance
t he is the managing director of of Al
Jazeera English post he assumed in the
fall of two thousand ten after a long
and distinguished career in broadcast
journalism in Australia in Britain in
America as both a correspondent and an
executive and as being one of the
founding crew of Al Jazeera English your
life may be filled with sorrows that I
don't know about but it sure seems from
here like you were a lucky guy to take
the helm just days before this fabulous
story broke and and you've done a great
job covering it and and we're proud to
present you with the Columbia Journalism
Award for 2011 and to ask you to speak
to us
it is thank you I certainly was lucky to
take over just before the most amazing
period in history and to use a phrase
it's not often used by a Brit but I've
just heard why does this feel good this
really is an honor to receive this award
ezzeddine said al jazeera english is a
four-year-old child we launched four and
a half years ago were made up of staff
and journalists from all over the world
30 plus nationalities in the newsroom
alone who came together in the pursuit
of good journalism and clear
storytelling so we're especially proud
to be recognized by the Columbia
Journalism school an institution
respected worldwide for its integrity
for its journalism and for the caliber
of the journalists that leave here it's
a magnificent event today I wasn't quite
expecting this so I'm delighted to be
here delighted to accept the ward and
delighted to see the class of 2011 enter
the world of journalism today so a big
thank you to columbia to the Dean and
his colleagues thank you to all of my
colleagues at al Jazeera English this is
a testament to their commitment and
dedication to journalism this is an
extraordinary time to be in the media
and an extraordinary time to be entering
into the media the Arab world is seeing
dramatic changes the landscape of that
region is changing day by day but the
wider world to is dominated by
fast-moving complicated stories just
look back at this year we started with
the Sudan the referendum the Ivory Coast
to change of leadership Japan any other
year japan would have been a lead story
now but it was in many respects dwarfed
by the enormity of the events in Egypt
and Syria and Libya in Tunisia the
interception of a Salman bin Laden and
of course the royal wedding
in a complicated fast-moving oftentimes
dangerous world people are craving
reliable information and without
trustworthy information divisions
between peoples the visions between
cultures are created by a lack of
understanding and those divisions are
being perpetuated without trustworthy
information and with opinion journalism
creeping into the mainstream some of
those information bridges risk being
blown arm we're operating in an
environment where trusted information is
scarce ER and scarcer and scarcer
citizen journalism is filling a gap and
it's hot on the heels of traditional
journalism as i call it the definition
of journalist is being questioned more
and more the fundamental role of the
media is being studied and challenged
are we opinion formers opinion makers
truth seekers storytellers rating
seekers or just damn good entertainers
what we do now in my view is important
as ever arguably more important now than
ever before our job is not to take sides
but to report all relevant sides of
stories all opinions and then dig hard
to try to get to the truth apply
integrity to everything we do we exist
to cover stories not to create them the
more complicated the story the more it
requires good journalism and in times of
conflict as we're seeing now spin often
turns to propaganda by versions become
Paul's lies and don't forget in the
midst of all of this are real people
often caught in the middle in the
crossfire but it's quite an example from
recent days as it demonstrates one of
the continuing daily challenges amid
some of the events that are taking place
in the Arab world just last week to open
is's eyewitnesses came on our air to
talk about what was going on in one
particular town in Syria that day a town
called Daraa the first two Syrian army
spokesperson he told us quote
the army entered Dara at the request of
residents to rid the city of terrorist
gangs who are responsible for a spate of
killings and vandalism just a couple of
hours later another eyewitness we
witnessed a massacre in Daraa the army
just went everywhere in the city they
attacked defenseless people 6,000 men
are being held they've been tortured by
the army and the regime bear in mind
when we reported those two eyewitness
statements electricity internet was cut
off to the city we were banned from
being there we were unable to have our
own journalists on the ground to witness
those events for ourselves to claim and
counterclaim within the space of two
hours and in the middle of it real
people's lives being overturned whatever
the truth is that it's worth digging for
journalism is about people's right to
know and in so many parts the world here
it is truly a matter of life and death
it's ironic them that despite the need
for journalism with integrity despite
the fact that the world is becoming
smaller flatter and more accessible to
its people despite the fact that the
events we are covering a seemingly ever
more complicated and interlinked we are
living in an age of the challenges to
journalism our ever-increasing the media
industry itself is facing a huge
commercial pressure right now the world
economy is in decline we report it every
day
you
in the world becoming smaller and more
accessible large parts of the world
remain uncovered and unreported add to
this the way that we're reporting news
hasn't changed much for some time the
world is a vast vast complicated place
stories erupted out of the blue news is
full of surprises no day is the same as
one of the reasons why we love it yet
the formula of news hasn't changed with
the evolving world look at the classic
standard bulletin 3 headlines last one
should be a teaser three packages a
light story at the end before you go
into the break at ease into the quality
of the story after the break interesting
story a couple of domestic stories for
an underlay sequence light story weather
wrap goodbye that was a rapid bulletin
no package longer than two minutes they
stand by it longer than seven seconds
for the world's a dynamic place is that
formula really representing the dynamism
of the world and as I ramifications of
the economic challenges arising the
power of spin is ever more pervasive the
world is full of sides we know that it's
full of different opinions politicians
corporations individuals all have an
interest in what we report and how we
report it they're well-versed at
amplifying and dampening news lines to
steer us on a course which is most
advantageous to them the machinery of
spin operates everywhere no matter where
you go in the world it's become an
endemic part of democracy and it's
become part of dictatorship no matter
where we're broadcasting from and
broadcasting to the message is massaged
the truth is disguised and all of this
is happening in the context of one very
important development new media and many
senses now media it's happening the
exponentially increasing conversation
about world events and about domestic
vents that's going on online is dwarfing
traditional media's prominence and
privilege in the information world
without reliable information people are
hunting out their own stories they're
finding their own facts people are
turning to one another
rather than traditional institutions to
find out what's going on and technology
is facilitating that dialogue and
engagement the rise of social media
means the world is now made up of
millions of eyewitnesses to events
bloggers are becoming the new
information providers mobile phone
camera people are becoming the
eyewitness reporters youtubers the new
television news twitter is putting
information into the public domain
whether we like it or not but be careful
that information sometimes is unverified
unfiltered unmoderated it can be an
articulation of opinion it can be an
articulation of fact where it can be
articulation of prejudice and sometimes
just bald lies contributors are
anonymous and unaccountable information
in the ether sphere perhaps devil's
advocate argument is telling you
everything and nothing at exactly the
same time so what is the boundary what
is the journalist in the new age of new
media well despite for some projections
and I'll cheer up now we're not saying
the death of journalism as we know it
we're seeing a marriage of old and new a
traditional journalism a new media for
this marriage it has no vows it has no
promises there's no prenuptial agreement
if the marriage fails there's no
external court to bring together the two
parties if needs be right now there are
no established rules for finding our
feet in this new world but we must make
that marriage work there's one other
aspect of new media that I think has to
be a key part of the discussion new
technologies are changing the way people
are receiving information as well as
interacting with it audiences want
information at a time and place of their
choosing not our choosing are they want
to interact with it in this April this
last month over 66 million people got
their information from Al Jazeera
English online over 61 million minutes
were watched live online in the same
period of time and 36 million minutes
that al Jazeera English was watched on
the iPhone alone and first quarter of
this year over half a million people get
there
news from us on Facebook for our sister
channel Al Jazeera Arabic in excess of 1
million people get their information
through Facebook this isn't just TV
Everywhere this is content everywhere
and all of the time we're going through
a fundamental change in the way that
people are digesting information and the
challenge I think for all of us is to
ensure that no matter what the platform
the integrity of that information is
always intact so amid all this change
what is the mission well for me the core
as i call it the journalism must be
protected the information must be
credible it must be trusted it must be
in depth must be done with integrity
eyewitness report firsthand journalism
original reporting it's the lifeblood of
what we do give the full story if it
needs explanation if it needs time if it
needs history if you need to add context
give it the time give the full picture
to our audiences listeners and viewers
out there hear the voices of the people
we talked about in Algeria the voice of
the voiceless that you're covering an
environmental summit you've got world
leaders in the site inside the summit
yes and there's lots and lots of cameras
filming those world leaders making very
important decisions in the corridors of
power but halfway around the world the
real people that are really impacted by
those decisions that are being made
let's hear the voices of those people
don't see the world through a prism we
talked about lots of different
perspectives if you narrow the prison
you narrow what's going on out there in
the world or in the country or in your
region but the countries of the world on
a level playing field look at the story
evaluate them on their merit cover all
sides of the story all relevant sides of
the story be devil's advocate when
you're all challenging those stories and
ask the challenging questions and as we
know when we gather so many people from
so many different backgrounds and
cultures challenge all of our own
preconceptions and we're studying how to
do the stories we do dig for the truth
and never accept anyone else's assumed
reality work in partnership with new
media tap into those eyewitness
reporters that are ever increasingly out
there in the world verify source that
video and information but encourage and
inspire
the contribution engage with the ethers
fear sometimes I think the best thing
that's happening to modern journalism to
engage with citizen journalists so that
people can be part of the dialogue and
the debate so despite the challenges
there is great cause for optimism and
this is an amazing event the future of
journalism is in this room there's no
doubt in my mind that the commitment to
journalism is very very much alive there
is a determination to rise above the
challenges a resolve to dig deeper and
to continue the quest for truth Andy
resolved to provide credible information
that facilitates a greater understanding
of what is happening in this world why
it's happening and ultimately what it
will mean into the future we held the
forum at the Newseum in Washington DC
yesterday I spent a few minutes just
walking around looking at the heyday the
golden era of journalism some of these
even I was not alive for Robert Kappas
photographs of d-day for example seymour
hersh's account of my li-- the New York
Times his publication of the Pentagon
Papers kikkan God's photograph of that
girl in Vietnam the victim of a napalm
attack Edward mario's radio reports from
World War two and of course the
Watergate reporting from Bob Woodward
and Carl Bernstein some of the greatest
journalism in history and on earth but
that spirit of truth telling that spirit
of holding power to account lives on
there are many of tens of thousands of
dedicated individuals who are giving
their all and sometimes risking all
searching for the truth and in the
pursuit of the democratic right for
people to know what's going on in their
world I'd like to mention two of our
journalists now Dorothy parvez and Kemal
Alta who dorothy was detained in syria
for a number of days and then moved to
iran detained in Iran and delighted to
say out last night
kemal detained in Libya we haven't heard
from him for a very long time both of
these people both of our journalists
were detained for doing a great job of
being great journalists and right now
we're calling for miles get out now from
Libya there are huge challenges facing
media journalism and journalists
worldwide but whatever barricades are
put in our way and your ways in the
future take on those challenges headlong
we've got to be resolute in calling for
the freedom of journalists to do their
job for the freedom of speech and for
the right worldwide to know and we must
continue to strive to take our
profession this ever changing rapidly
evolving profession into the future with
integrity with credibility and with
truth so we're living through
extraordinary times at the moment and I
feel that's going to continue for many
months if not years to come this is an
extraordinary time for Al Jazeera and it
is a true honor to receive this so on
behalf of everyone at Al Jazeera English
but also my colleagues at our sister
channel Al Jazeera Arabic and all of our
staff for Al Jazeera network this is a
testament to them and thank you very
much
thank you you to get a Columbia
Journalism school tote bag just one
other word about this you know nate
silver was quite eloquent on a number of
fronts in speaking to us yesterday and
one point he made is that as a
journalist you have to attend to your
own sort of brand identity and be
prepared to move hither and yon and he's
right on the other hand institutions
matter also and the archipelago of
really significant journalistic
institutions that hold dear the values
that a lance they just laid out in his
talk is not infinite I hope this school
is one of them and when there's a new
one it's a really important development
for our profession and al jazeera
english is a new one and and it's a
wonderful thing to have individual
achievement but it's also a wonderful
thing to create a significant and we
hope lasting new institution producing
news now for a sort of quasi surprise
one of our graduating students this year
katama Cahill jackson happens to be
grandson of pete seeger who needs no
real introduction of the famous and
legendary folk singer he is here for the
graduation and he's agreed to come up to
the stage and entertain this for a few
minutes so please welcome Pete Seeger
if any of you have lived in Albany
you've heard the first verse of a song
written by a working newspaper man who
lived in California 60 years ago and
because at age 92 my memory is going
right now I'm trying to remember his
memory remember his name maybe I'll
remember it before because I thought you
should hear two more verses in his song
newspapermen leads us at arresting
people they know the lowdown now it can
be told I'll tell you quite reliably off
the record about some charming people I
have tingling of a city desk who the
press open press extra extra read all
about it it's a mess beats a test on
this payment such interesting people
it's wonderful to represent that oh you
remember mrs. eighties magery she wanted
money to buy her new fur coat to get
insurance she employed called the green
she up and caught her husband's only
throat ting-a-ling-a-ling sitting desk
home the press oh no I left out of line
she talked him into fragments she
stuffed it in her truck she shipped it
all about yonder to her uncle in podunk
own uzbek amendments upset arresting
people it must have startled her parole
Sadie's UNK tickling later city desk
hold breasts holy the press extra extra
read all about it it's a best eats at
this
newspapermen meet such interesting
people it's wonderful to represent the
press Oh publishers are such interesting
people their policies and acrobatic
finger they claim to represent the
common people it's funny Wall Street
never has complained Harvard publishers
of worries for publishers must go to
working folks for readers and the big
shots for her donor for social sucks
interesting people
could be restitution I don't know
ting-a-ling-ling the circulation to
guilty lame advertising get those
readers get that pay off what a headache
but a press publishers are such
interesting let's give three chairs for
freedom of the press
must have been 40 years ago I got a
letter from one of my publishers saying
Pete can't you write another song like
goodnight Irene I can't market these
protest songs you keep singing I was a
little angry I pulled a slip of paper
out of my pocket which I copies out an
extraordinary poem I've been reading the
book of Ecclesiastes in the Bible but I
found out since then his Hebrew name was
Calif meaning con Volker people who
calls be people together and I had just
bought a little tape recorder and I
improvised a tune mailed it off a couple
weeks later I got a nice letter from the
publisher saying just what I was looking
for he got it to an extraordinary
electric band the birds and they sent
this song around the world if anybody
knows it hope you sing with me it sounds
a lot better than my cracked old voice
do everything is a season and a time for
every purpose
you can see that can't
to everything
we return three times
i'll give you the word simple versus so
you can sing them too
oops
at a time
have the time
repurpose a time to be born a time to
die a time to become the
to plant to reap a time to plant but
to kill to heal a time to kill but turn
the left too weak to everything two at a
time
purpose the time to build up a time to
break down a time to build a time to
dance to mourn a time to dance the time
to cast away stones a time to cast
together time together they get some
harmony on that course now to everything
some because they do everything to
everything
I
time of love the time of hate a timer
time you may
a time to gain the time to lose our time
to get to render to Seoul odd time to
read hutton a love-hate art I have a
timepiece p I swear it's not
time had that time for repurpose
I can't resist and there's also a time
to graduate and this is it at
yesterday's journalism award ceremony
student prizes and honors were awarded i
would like to reprise the list of
winners now first I'd like to call your
attention to the students who are
graduating with honors i'm going to call
out a list of names please stand as I
read your name and rest of you please
withhold your applause until the end
here we go Vegas else Jason Alcorn
Alexandra alper elizabeth anderson
willow Belden Edward Shawn Jonah
Comstock Elizabeth Davies Jennifer
depriest Lauren docket tamir elterman
Amara grotsky Samuel guzik Joshua
Haskell Lisa held Mary Johnson Jamie
Joyce Ashley Killough no echo javi
evonik at asava lynn LA neha rica moon
der Sar moon Donna Anna Merlan Joshua
Moyer Rodney muhumuza with richard
nieves Catherine Olson Nicholas Pandolfo
Cesare epod cool Robin respo Albert
Samaha yar Dennis Schwartz quieres OTA
eaten son Jason tomasini Kaitlyn trembly
been waltzer charrisse williams and
Steven wit now you may apply
now L replot reprise the winners of the
awards that we presented yesterday so
that parents and guests may share the
honors with our graduates same drill
I'll call your name please remain
standing an audience please hold your
applause until the end the Richard T
Baker Bronx Inc award went to Ethan
froggatt the Richard T Baker Brooklyn
Inc award went to Ivana cuts ova the
Richard T Baker Columbia new service
award went to Amara grotsky the Richard
T Baker Award for literary journalism
went to Vegas oz Richard T Baker
magazine production award went to
Pauline I Furman the Richard T Baker
magazine production award to Leah Cooper
the Richard T Baker magazine writing
award went to a tusa abraha mian the
Richard T Baker magazine writing award
went to Anna Merlan the noble a Kian
award for literary criticism to Delaney
Hall best ma thesis award town now amis
eville of the runners-up for that award
Delaney hall and Rachel aeronca the
Richard blood scholarship Lauren docket
and ELISA vine the DuPont Judy have
Crichton documentary award to mark habra
and Sarah Fitzpatrick the Phillip Greer
award to Elizabeth Davies from the MS
program and Duncan Wilson from the MA
program the Robert Herron award to
Antoine gara the Fred M Hechinger
journalism education award to Monica
Busan and Jason tomassini the Horgan
prizes for excellence of critical
science writing when first place Nathan
Hearst second place Carla klippstein
third place Elliot Ross the outstanding
journalism editorial-writing award went
to atossa Abrahamian Peter Keller
editing prize Amanda rents Joan Connor
broadcast journalism award to Jennifer
depriest the law prize to willow Belden
and Andrew to silver the linen
fellowship in book prizing to Jamie
Joyce and Steven
the melvin mentor award to Cesare epod
cool the Lars Erik Nelson cries to josh
moyer the photo journalism award to
saskia de rothschild the Henry and
Taylor award to Vegas us the James a
Wexler award for international reporting
to muhammad bilal LA County the James a
Wexler award for local reporting to
Robin respo the Lewis Winnick prize to
nicht Pandolfo the digital media
interactive design prize to Jason
tomassini excellence in digital media
interactive workshop prize to Jason
Alcorn the digital media multimedia
storytelling prize to do a cook and
Chitra Chidori digital media visual
storytelling priced at lint at nightly
news workshop prized and pallavi ready
and Ignacio Torres the radio workshop
rise to willow Belden the video
storytelling workshop to Elizabeth
Davies and tamir elterman ok you can
clap now
now I'm going to repeat the names of the
recipients of the awards to the highest
ranking students in the class the
pulitzer traveling fellowships part of
joseph pulitzer's founding legacy to the
school which go to five outstanding
students to enable them to travel and
study abroad one pulitzer traveling
fellowship is presented to a student
with a special interest in the arts and
arts criticism that one went to Jimmy so
next fellowship to willow Belden next to
niharika mandhana next to Samuel guzik
and the last one to the top student in
the class Elizabeth Davies
I'm now going to turn the microphone
over for the rest of the ceremony to our
Dean of Student Affairs and graduation
day pronunciations are three screen
navasana swear you come on up just
getting organized here folks let's give
mr. seeger a big hand
there he is just taking his seat when I
arrived in this country as a
nine-year-old fresh off the boat his
songs were among the very first we
learned at PS 6 and today I got to see
him sitting in that seat with a banjo on
his knee good afternoon everyone big big
congrats to all our graduates I told you
it would go fast nine months for our ma
students 10 month 10 months for our MS
students and several short ears for our
PhD students as you know i love inviting
all of you to events so here is another
friday's orientation for our next group
of part-time students for 30 p.m.
stabile student center reception be
there it is my honor now to introduce
you to graduates from 40 countries and
35 States some of the names you will
hear today will not be familiar to you
for three reasons one some students have
chosen to use a more traditional form
and pronunciation instead of the more
Americanized versions you're used to to
some have chosen their full formal names
in all their glory rather than the more
nicknaming names you know them by and
the third reason I'll simply get them
wrong so let me apologize in advance to
all the parents grandparents aunts
uncles and distant relatives after whom
these students have been named I
apologize and I'm sorry now on with the
show I'd like to ask assistant dean of
students Melanie Huff to join me on the
stage and Dean Nicholas lemon
before you meet the grads I'd like to
acknowledge 10 students who began their
program with all these students but were
selected to stay for a special advanced
documentary program under professor June
cross they will get their degrees in
October please hold your applause till I
have read all the names and students
please stand as I recognize you Ashley
similar Diana Neil Eric pattern Oh eNOS
OT ova a member of the United States
Armed Forces for a veteran of the United
States Armed Forces Jonathan hall Martin
markovits matthew kelly patrick martin
Menard Sanaa goals are and Sandhya Dirks
you all have the blue program in front
of you you can take it out but it will
not help you keep track of how much time
we have left because we are not reading
them in that order I'll be reading out
names by the students classes the
special classes they were in their main
courses and they'll be getting their
diplomas from their professors so I will
announce the name of each professor
who's giving out the diploma and then
read the name the hometown and the names
of the students all right here we go
first presenter is Professor Elena
Cabral yes please applaud as they I
bring them up she'll be presenting our
october two thousand ten candidates and
getting their masters of science degrees
first up from Denver Colorado Ryan our
from New York and bogota colombia
mariana kristen show on our next
presenter is Professor Robin rising
from Garden City New York Alexis Leon
this from New York New York Andrea
mourad our next presenter is Professor
Beth White House from Flushing New York
richard allen chen professor Sam
Friedman is our next presenter
substituting for professor Beth White
House our next presenter are our next
student from lansing michigan been
Walter and Kieran
our next presenters professor addy
Rimmer from Hopkinton Massachusetts
William W new Brander then ask professor
Isaac to come back and our next student
our next graduate from Atlantic Beach
Florida is Mary Kay Johnson next we have
our PhD students newly minted PhDs
presenting will be professor Andy Tucker
from when Osiris are in Tina dr. pablo
calvi from vancouver canada via texas
dr. Joe cut birth from Greenwich
Connecticut doctors sophie guite next
we'll be presenting our master of arts
students and they are took
concentrations in arts Paul business
politics and science our first two
presenters in the arts program a
professor's Alisa Solomon and David Haye
do
from New York New York Shira dicker from
Summit New Jersey Alexander George from
Albuquerque New Mexico Delaney hall from
Bombay India perizaad Khan from
changchun china joy dongle MA from San
Juan Puerto Rico Nuria net from Edmonton
Canada Alyssa Noel from hong kong Jimmy
so
from Atlanta Georgia Jennifer Camille
Thomas from you follow Alabama Tracy
Tory Thompson also receiving her master
of science degree our next presenters
from the business concentration are
professors james stewart and sylvia
nasar from Flushing New York Tanya
benedicto from New York City Antoine
gara from Brooklyn New York Linda Louise
lacina from Lagos Nigeria chechi Okonkwo
from Copenhagen Denmark Natalia rockland
from Dublin Ireland Nev Sweeney from her
feet china one shoe from Wellington New
Zealand Duncan Wilson our next
presenters are from the politics
concentration and the presenters are
professor alexander still oh and Tom
Etzel from Kulemin in New South Wales
Australia Alice Lynette Marika Brennan
that makes it easy just shout over the
name then I don't have to worry about
getting it right let's see if we can do
that with all of them let's be perfect
from McClain Virginia Katherine Myers
done from Cedar Rapids Iowa Erica fry
from Pretoria and South Africa Leo me
Kirk r-ill no one more low a me creo
from diego martin in trinidad and tobago
gold Ali from Brooklyn New York Thor new
rider from Columbus Ohio will Loomis
from Minsk in Belarus Maria seduce kiya
from trondheim in Norway sieve sandwich
from alhambra california Rachel
Gabriella rangga from ogden utah Naomi's
Elif our next presenters from the
science concentration professors
Marguerite Holloway and Professor
Jonathan winner
from Baltimore Maryland alison becker
from Rochester Minnesota Kirk clucky
from New York New York Vivian marks from
Chennai India Vivian I are from
Larchmont New York Daniel Rosen from New
York from newark delaware Rose Eileen
Tobin from Virginia Beach Virginia
Ashley Jean winners Heron next will be
recognizing students from two separate
mid-career fellowship programs the first
are the night badgett fellows and
they'll be receiving a master of science
degree and a certificate in economics
and business journalism presenting the
diplomas or professor terry thompson and
from new york new york Jill Bosch a new
york new york Peter belair Sacramento
California Christian berthelsen from
Portland Oregon Andrew Carl the silver
from woodside New York Jennifer hailey
from Houston Texas Renee Moreau from New
York New York Alexander Osipova CH from
New York New York Matthew Phillips from
brookline massachusetts Seth Stevenson
next will be recognizing one of our
Spencer fellows in education journalism
and presenting the diplomas professor
Linnell Hancock malikov City Maryland
greg toppo now will be recognizing our
students with our masters of science in
journalism
first up our professors Lenny borin and
Dodi cient are from Berkeley California
tamir elterman from Los Alamos New
Mexico Ethan Copley froggatt from Paree
frost Lou in bear plano texas ashley
killough from seoul korea hiring rose
kim from bangalore india russia kumar
from plur Ephraim Salaam oooo song from
Island Park New York Dennis Murphy from
Toronto Canada roshni Murthy from
Buffalo New York Caitlin Palumbo from
matar catalonia Gisela parrot morir
from Athens Georgia Apollo v ready from
fort lauderdale florida alexa west from
Seoul Korea Audrey you our next
presenters are professors Elenna cabral
and Rhoda Lipton
from Houston Texas Jacob Anderson on New
York New York willow Belden from Sumter
South Carolina Melanie Monique Brisbane
from Bombay India chitrangada Chaudhary
from Seattle Washington seyla for ku
mana from saline Michigan Terran and
Hartman from Queens New York ilysm or
gene from cluster New Jersey Michelle Oh
from Boston Massachusetts Melissa and
Pirelli from Toronto Canada Kumu da
ramanathan from Dallas Texas angel
lenise from eaton from Hayward
California Ignacio Torres
from bremen germany monica was sued our
next presenters or professors and cooper
and betsy west from Beirut Lebanon Linda
Abby I see from quay quay Zimbabwe Kim
Chang I check Anita from London England
Sara Elizabeth's Fitzpatrick from Los
Angeles California Katrina's day from
Los Angeles California Katrina Kaufman
from Karachi Pakistan muhammad bilal
Akane from Tampa Florida veteran from
Tampa Florida veteran of the US Marine
Corps alexander luck answer from san
francisco california carlos my organ
from England and Pakistan zara Akbar
Raja
from Londonderry New Hampshire Robin
Michelle respo from bogota colombia
ingrid rojas from east hartford
connecticut who liana shots from Sonoma
California Kiara so T lame you gotta
give the broadcast faculty extra hugging
time from burbank california brett tio
from Mexico City Carla's a budovsky our
next presenters are professors laura
muha and june cross from Torrance
California zareen adamjee from from
Petaluma California marrows beg from
singapore and tokyo Chang hyung-jin from
Malibu California Olivia Rochelle
dimande from Dayton Ohio Joseph a daniel
wits
from glasgow united kingdom Elizabeth
Davies from plur e4 saskia de Rothschild
from Los Angeles California Joshua
Bernstein Haskell from Delhi India
diksha Medoc from Nigeria chin y agua
from Oradell New Jersey Andrea park from
garden grove california jacqueline quinn
from perth australia Harriet Riley from
Allentown Pennsylvania umer mohammed
from San Francisco California Mimi wells
from Toronto Canada semhar Waldo yes s
our next presenters professor Anthony de
palma
from Clinton New Jersey Laura Christine
Headley from Warwick New York Lisa
Elaine held from Stockholm Sweden Celia
cone from Athens Greece Joanna Katarina
nikis from forest hills queens Catherine
burns Olson from Franklin Park Illinois
sorry put cold from rockville maryland
Alice Popovich our next presenters
professor John dingus
from Bethesda Maryland Alex Alper from
Clearwater Florida amaris castillo from
Phoenix Arizona michael raymond e el
castillo from Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
Kaitlyn cocina CH from Beirut Lebanon
leick iata from Mumbai India Sonia
katani from Caracas Venezuela alejandro
lopez dro from Yorktown New York Beth
Alice Morsi from ball fell deutschland
miranda neubauer from Hayward California
richard joseph nibble from fullerton
california bryan park
from Caracas Venezuela Manuel Louie Dom
from Schenectady New York Alicia Santo
from Linden New Jersey Camilo Hannibal
Smith from San Diego California latoya
maria tools from New York New York
Steven wit our next presenters professor
sam friedman from miami florida michelle
bialik from new york new york denis de
wanna blow steam from miami florida
Christina Merrill from New York New York
Andrea Ricci a from Haven Kansas jessica
scott from Brooklyn New York nakia
Denise Bradley from Jay Florida Megan
young blood our next presenters
professor ari Goldman
I am joined by dr. Joe cut birth he was
teaching in the program when he was a
student in the ph.d program from
Brooklyn New York Joseph Alexio from
Bronx New York estate buyers from bryn
mawr Pennsylvania Heather Marguerite
Higgins from huntington new york
Christian Roman from Pelham New York
Todd stone our next presenter is
Professor Linnell Hancock presenting
with Professor Cara with Sir with
Professor Barbara kantrowitz from Los
Angeles California David Patrick
Alexander Forest Hills New York
Elizabeth Catherine Anderson from Newton
Massachusetts Stephanie Elizabeth
Epstein from Chicago Illinois Brent our
dough from florence in italia letra few
me
from grafton massachusetts ameri grotsky
from Wellington New Zealand Nicola keen
from Brooklyn New York Knick Pendle fo
from West Hartford Connecticut Catherine
pearson from bonus iris Argentina Connie
pretty from Dallas Texas arasima Romero
from greenfield massachusetts zachary
stanched on Braun from parsippany new
jersey are Danish warts from Tianjin
China getting Sun from half moon New
York Caitlin Tremblay our next
presenters are professors David clay
tell and Howard French from Washington
DC Maria Jose Aguilar from hope of Saudi
Arabia ahmed al Imran from Arlington
Massachusetts alejandra liliuokalani
borunda from New York New York katama
Shabazz Cahill Jackson from Philadelphia
Pennsylvania Francesca Crozier
Fitzgerald
from Detroit Michigan amira Olivia david
from charlotte north carolina anna
elizabeth Edgerton hulu Dolph rose
Elaine fractional from Singapore patient
0 from Baltimore Maryland jewel
Antoinette Johnson broadcast faculty and
others need lots of extra time from
London England Lucy kinder from Paramus
New Jersey Amy Cooper in ski from bond
in deutschland benno Muller from
Sacramento California Dexter Rashad
Mullins from Laguna Hills California
James Plunkett from San Jose California
linh tat from Nevada City California
Bronwyn tome our next presenters
professor dale maharaj from new york new
york playa karachi pakistan cortland ali
khan
from Perry Fras Pauline I furman from
San Rafael California Simone Goren dough
from Guangzhou China Winnie goo from
Santa Fe New Mexico Ryan may handy from
Stevens Point Wisconsin Nathan Hurst
from London you in the United Kingdom
Nick Jardine from London England Megan
Eileen kennelly from Detroit Michigan
Timothy Kaczynski from San Francisco
California Laura renee marie from
torrington connecticut kate pool from
Sacramento California Albert conception
Samaha from San Francisco California
Tatiana yanira Sanchez from Camp Zama
Japan Arvind temper from Colombo Sri
Lanka rocknes whatever the name our next
presenters are professors mere toh hito
and Karen's to be nerve
from Buenos Aires Argentina Andres
caballero from San Francisco California
Svetlana Dottie Renko from Copenhagen
Denmark lara's Christian wit barrel from
says of Poland Anna Maria yeah Kubek
from Medford Massachusetts Daniel Carl
Johnson from Huntington West Virginia
Lacy and Johnson from Jerusalem Israel
Noah co javy from New York New York
Lynette Paula lopez from Lima Peru
sandro murata leak looking from
Bangalore India niharika mandhana from
Birmingham England himanshu oh job from
Bridgetown Barbados makita Korea monisha
Peters from Toronto Canada julia pyper
from Lake Tahoe California Chloe shield
house from Jamestown North Carolina
Caitlin Elizabeth you go lick from
Berkeley California Ryan Villarreal from
Long Island New York April Jan Warren
our next presenters are professors Ruth
paddler and Pamela Frederick from
Mission Viejo California gray Beltran
from Hackettstown New Jersey lauren
brown from Cambridge Massachusetts Simon
Doolittle from Washington DC Amelia
Newell ferrara from Nogales Arizona Juan
Gastelum from rosslyn New York Sam gozok
from Prague in the Czech Republic ivana
kata so far from Jerusalem Israel Ruth
mullet from kampala uganda Rodney
muhumuza from Bogota Colombia Maria
potosi from Santa Barbara California
benjamin thomas Preston with Sacramento
California Richard Hamilton Proctor from
Leith Scotland Elliot Ross from
Huntington Beach California Arlene check
my John from New York New York Linda
throws a ball from Addis Ababa Ethiopia
Eden Ezra Walder guy our next presenters
professor sandy pad way from Geneva
Switzerland to saw Abrahamian
from granville Ohio Leah Evan banquets
from Chapel Hill North Carolina Leah
fake Cooper from homs syria holid ruby
from durham north carolina John Harrison
urbana illinois umair elf on from
singapore shabani mitani from pembroke
pines pembroke pines florida Tony and
Martin from Caracas Venezuela Clara
Martinez Turco Laramie Wyoming Nathaniel
messy from Santa Fe New Mexico Anna
Francesca Merlin from Pottsville
Pennsylvania Josh Moyer from Woodmere
New York slow mo sprung from New York in
the United States accompanied by Lorenzo
Zapata two months old Michelle are
restless tavares from New York New York
Erica wolf
our next presenters are professors Robin
reisig and Michelle Michelle slit ello
and Andrea can appel alright three
professors I better slow down from
Chandigarh India abajo bends from
Cumberland Maryland Catherine bulge from
new york new york jarrod Samuels
Baumeister from kingwood texas Timothy D
bella from miami florida Ashley Callaway
from Indianapolis Indiana Jonah Clark
comstock from Aston Pennsylvania Liz day
from Middletown New York Ashley Dean
from New York New York Vladimir do ta
from London in the United Kingdom Ruby
Edwards from Indianapolis Indiana
Benjamin fear no from New York New York
Zachary fryer Biggs from Sao Paulo
Brazil Luis Garcia
from chennai india lakshmi kumaraswamy
from Portland Oregon Emily Marie little
from London in the united kingdom Leila
milana Ellen from fremont california
Janine celeste pang from New York New
York Rama ready Raghavan from New York
New York Christina Suzanne you Scotty
from newburyport massachusetts alyssa
vine from singapore sarika a gear Yadav
from Seattle Washington Leslie yay our
next presenters our professors addy
Rimmer and dr. Joe cut birth from New
York New York Jennifer the priest
from Delhi India Sohail Khan from
Greenport New York Melissa Taylor
Kahndaq from sneads Florida Paige Rentz
from Scarborough Maine patricia lynn
summers from Los Angeles California
Charisse Williams presenting for
professor chip Scanlon is Dean good bill
grew skin from Bethesda Maryland Jeremy
brotman whites our next presenter is
Professor Michael Shapiro from Bergen in
Norway veigar tunneled hace from Nairobi
Kenya adil up sheer from Bronx New York
Elaine almonds are from Arad Romania
Rebecca Roxanna broto from Jacksonville
Florida Joseph dough from nyack new york
alexander ericsson from new york new
york Alex Nicholas geekin
from karachi pakistan maria cringy from
Los Angeles California Michael Henry
Keller from San Jose California Lin lue
law from lynn massachusetts Evan Matthew
McDonald from Baltimore Maryland joy
marie murphy Mackenzie l'amour
California Joe proud men from Brooklyn
New York Lillian Rizzo from Detroit
Michigan camera Noel Thomas from
Istanbul Turkey jail on you can it sue
our next presenter is Professor Paula
span
from Bedford New York jason s Alcorn
from Batavia New York salaamay Anderson
from Johannesburg in South Africa Zahir
Kassim